MALE SPEAKER: Good morning
and welcome to Talks at Google
in Cambridge, Mass.
Today it's my great
pleasure to introduce
one of the most interesting
people I know, Bill Powers.
Bill has worked for two
decades in development aid
and conservation in Latin
America, Africa and North
America.
From 2002 to 2004 he managed
the community components
of a project in
the Bolivian Amazon
that won a 2003 prize for
environmental innovation
from the Kennedy School
of Government at Harvard.
He's worked at the
World Bank and holds
international relations degrees
from Brown and Georgetown.
He's a Senior Fellow at
the World Policy Institute
and an adjunct faculty member
at New York University.
"New Slow City" is his
fourth book for adults.
They're all excellent, and
you can read more about them
on his website
www.williampowersbook.com.
So, burned out after years of
doing everything I just listed,
Bill spent a season in
a 12 foot by 12 cabin
off the grid in North Carolina.
He then attempted to
do something similar
in New York City.
I suspect we're about to get
an entirely new perspective
on work life balance, as
well as the benefit of Bill's
extensive experience in
international affairs.
Please join me in
welcoming, Bill Powers.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL POWERS: Thank you.
Thanks very much for
coming on a Monday morning
to this gathering.
It's just a great pleasure
to be here at Google.
I use your products and I
think they're wonderful.
And, because you're such
an intelligent audience,
I'm going to try to pack
a lot in to this hour we
have together.
And I'm going to really give
some perspectives on what
is the philosophical
underpinning for these new slow
movements and movements towards
minimalism and simplicity
and work life balance,
and why it's happening now
with the environmental crisis
and the triple threat that's
happening.
And I'm also going to share
some personal experiences
from my own life-- this journey
that Jonathan was talking
about from New York City,
all around the world,
to a tiny 12 by 12
cabin in North Carolina,
and so on-- as a way of
provoking questions and maybe
inspiring you to think
about some new things
that you can do in your
work and your life.
You take from it what you will.
So with that said,
we're in this moment
of what you might call
the Great Turning,
where there are related
movements around slow issues.
Like fast food is being
replaced by slow food.
You know about
this slow movement.
There's 6,000 conviviums
around the country.
People get together
and prepare local foods
and eat them with friends.
Also, of course, having
a more vegetarian diet
or eating lower on the
food chain, of course,
has less greenhouse gas
emissions, another advantage.
There's also slow
money, which looks
at how we're
investing our capital.
Is it being invested
in big agribusiness,
for example, that contributes
a lot of chemicals
and monocultures, or is it going
toward sustainable agriculture?
The issue of work life
balance is actually
tied into the culture
of "fast and more"
and the response to it.
So I know here at
Google there's been
a lot of efforts to have
flextime and other things
that you're experimenting with.
You probably know that Carlos
Slim, the world's richest man,
called for a three day work week
recently, and has repeated it
many times.
He says, it will happen.
He says most recently that he's
realized through his career
that, really, life is about
more than just working.
And actually you can
get a ton of efficiency
into these three 11-hour
days, and then have four days
to refresh yourself,
have creative pursuits
and come back to work
much more changed.
So I don't know
if you know-- does
this have a little
pointer on it?
Yeah, it does.
So the United States,
actually, is the lowest amount
of leave in the
industrialized world.
We only have 12 days.
And there's this whole Take
Back Your Time movement.
Who's heard of Take Back Your
Time day, October 24 each year?
It's the day when Europeans
could stop working
and Americans have to work
to the end of the year,
because they get nine
weeks more vacation
than we do on average a year.
That's how much more.
And these are other
industrialized countries.
So it's a way of saying, I mean,
even medieval peasants worked
less than we did, in
terms of number of hours.
If you look at how
productivity from 1970-2010
has actually gone
four folds, including
using the kind of tools
that you're making, and yet
our hours have gone up.
Why is it that the
average hour of work
is four times more
productive, and yet we're
working more hours,
and much more
than are industrialized
counterparts?
Another sort of model
that's out there,
that you may have heard of--
who's heard of transition?
Transition towns?
Very few of you.
Well, basically, the
idea is that we're
in this era of kind
of fossil fuels
and we need to get
to more solar, winds.
We're also in an era
of mass organization,
and why not look more at small?
So small is beautiful.
Getting back to
models of organization
at the neighborhood level,
the community level.
So in New York City,
for example there's
transition neighborhoods in New
York, where you're looking at,
like, how we source our
energy for that neighborhood,
where we get our food.
How can you source
it more effectively?
So all over the world, and more
so in England than anywhere,
there are these transition
communities really figuring
out how to be self
sustainable in a world
where fossil fuels become
less and less viable
in terms of climate change.
And this is an example of
a sort of transition town
type of communities
and architecture,
designing with nature.
Biomimicry, mimicking
the way nature
creates and creating our
architecture that way,
even in cities-- how we
can look at human well
being as the basis for how
we're organizing things
and create around that.
Even walking around
here in Kendall Square,
it's beautiful, MIT is
very nice, all of this,
but what if we
had it even nicer?
What if there were
more buildings that
were kind of shaped
around nature?
There's the whole environmental
psychology, or eco psychology
area that's out now, that
they're looking at the fact
that human's
relationship with nature
is part of our emotional
and social well being.
And when we cut that cord,
we're bound to feel depressed.
And a lot of the kind of
neuroses and bipolar disorders
and everything is actually
tied to this disconnection
with nature.
E. O. Wilson talks about this
in his biomimicry theory.
So these types of transition and
green architecture activities
actually help that as well.
So there's all these things
that are in this great turning.
Unfortunately, there is this
culture of fast and more.
And let me just clarify
that when I say slow,
I'm not talking about
always going slow.
I'm talking about
being self-paced--
being able to determine the
rhythm of your own life,
having the control
of that and to be
able to vary the
rhythm, the tempo
gusto, the right speed,
as they say in music.
So we're in this system
where, unfortunately,
the industrial model
of growth is leading
to this type of water shortage.
Last week in San Paolo they
had massive water shortages,
which caused riots.
This is caused by climate
change and deforestation.
As you know in
China, for example,
the pollution from
coastal China spreads
across the rest of Asia.
Their environmental problems
are not respecting boundaries.
And we have, in
Bolivia, where I'm
currently living-- we left New
York for Bolivia last year,
and that's another story which
I'll tell you about-- but this
is the example of deep poverty
interacting with cycles
of slash and burn agriculture,
cutting down the rain forests.
And at the same time
huge monocropping.
So I talked about
slow money, investing
in sustainable agriculture.
When you just have your
investment in-- this
is Archer Daniel the
Midlands, ADM in Bolivia,
cutting down huge amounts of
rain forest for our grains
and so on.
So I mean, you really have to
look at what we're doing here
and how it's felt
around the world.
For example, this is the
border of Bolivia and Brazil,
where we are right now.
This is Bolivia--
Bolivia, Bolivia, Bolivia.
And as you can see,
the Brazilian side
is totally cut down for
soy, for chia-- the new crop
that everyone's growing, for
cattle ranching and so on.
Bolivia is still that
more uninhabited boundary,
but the same process
is coming there.
Luckily, however, there
is no global warming.
Do you see this?
Yeah, they just confused
Fahrenheit and Celsius.
There's no problem with global
warming-- not really, of course
there is.
I don't have to talk
to you about this.
I'm sure everyone here
knows about the problem.
I mean, just walk outside today.
Or look at last winter,
how extreme it was.
All of these changes
that we're seeing,
even here in New England,
is very, very clearly
even felt more
strongly in places
like Greenland or Bolivia.
This is Bolivia
Chacaltaya Mountain.
This was Bolivia's
only ski resort.
In just a matter of
decades it's gone
from being a glacier to nothing.
So they had to close
the ski resort recently.
It doesn't exist
anymore, because like all
the other glaciers in
Bolivia, they're melting.
And it's affecting the water
supply for millions of people.
So these are the
types of issues that
have led even countries
like the Maldives
to have their cabinet
meetings underwater.
This is the president
of the Maldives,
and they're actually signing
legislation under water
to show that their country
is about to go under.
And in my own city in New York,
of course, Hurricane Sandy
and the effect that
it had, our building
was out of power for two weeks
and everything was flooded.
There was environmental
refugees in New York.
My students at NYU were in
the Bronx like in shanties.
It was just terrible.
For two weeks, we
were feeling it there.
And of course, a lot of this
is tied in with, sort of,
subsidies for oil and gas and
hardly anything for renewables.
But we don't have to
go into that in detail.
So all this anecdotal stuff and
all these different examples
is tied into a very
stark fact, and that's
this-- that our
average footprint
of the average American
is five planets.
This is UN scientists
who say that it
would take five
planets of resources
if everyone lived at our
level of consumption.
That is an extreme
point of view.
And the reason is because of
what we call over development.
So there's development,
and then there's
under development, which is
like maybe 20% of humanity's
underdeveloped, starving,
in war zones without enough.
60% of humanity is
developed, that's
subsistence, agriculture,
living with enough.
And then there's
overdevelopment.
Overdevelopment is
taking it too far.
And the kind of mega diversity
that you see in a place
like Bolivia, unfortunately,
is turning into this.
I just recently
found these photos.
This is the new mall in Santa
Cruz, the first mall in Bolivia
that's come.
And it's just amazing to see
the chains, like McDonald's
and Hard Rock and
everything coming
into the city and
this enormous mall.
It's really, to
me, quite shocking
because this is the
Bolivia that I know,
and this is where
we're going with it.
So I'm talking about a big
philosophical issue that
actually led me to be
kind of depressed after 10
years of working.
Yeah, we had prize winning
projects from the JFK school
in rain forests in Bolivia,
with carbon sequestration.
We had all kinds of
incredible things
we were doing that
were successful,
but with five
planets of resources,
sometimes it felt
like it was in vain.
So after 10 years of
working abroad-- just
to tell you a personal story--
I came back to the US in 2007,
and I ended up
living in this cabin.
It was a 12 foot by
12 foot cabin off
grid in North Carolina.
It's a permaculture farm.
And can you picture what 12
foot by 12 foot is, like how big
that is?
AUDIENCE: Less than
what you're standing on.
BILL POWERS: Right.
So maybe-- why don't
just do a little thing
just so we can understand it.
Can you guys, can
you four stand up
here and try to arrange
yourself 12 by 12.
See if you can do that.
So is that right?
AUDIENCE: No, [INAUDIBLE].
BILL POWERS: Too big, right!
I'm probably going
off camera, but let me
just come down
for a second here.
So like this is
basically-- yeah,
maybe you would
have to be here--
but basically, this was the
12 bu 12 and what it was like.
So this is where I lived.
Yeah, that's perfect.
Thank you.
OK.
So just to give
you a visual here,
I would come into
the house, like this.
And there was one bed up
in a loft, a little place
to cook with natural gas
here, and a rocking chair
over here in the corner, and
the entrance and candles.
And that was it.
And this belongs to a physician
in North Carolina, who actually
downsized from a big house
and moved into this thing.
And she's been living
in it for 10 years,
and she invited me to
live there for a season.
So you can imagine being
in the middle of American
and living in this tiny 12
by 12, kind of blew me away.
I was there, actually, spring.
It was like end of
winter into spring.
So even when it's cold,
there's no wood burning stove.
You use more layers.
You know, homo sapiens,
we're a strong species.
We adapt to lots
of environments.
And that's what I also realized
working around the world
and living in this
12 by 12, especially,
was that you can adapt to it.
So this just gives
you a little--
thank you for showing something.
AUDIENCE: No heat?
BILL POWERS: No heat at all.
It is North Carolina,
of course, so it
has to be adapted to whatever
environment you're in.
And just to give you
some more images,
like this is the model that
this physician, Doctor Jackie
Benton, is modeling.
So there is the 12 by 12, which
only costs $7,000 to build.
$10,000 for her land, two acres
full of permaculture paradise
of 200 species of crops
and so on, a little no name
creek over here.
It's this type of a design
with rainwater catchments.
Yeah, everything off the
grid and she lives there.
And these are the
types of neighbors,
you know, you get all
this organic produce.
It was sort of like what I was
used to experiencing in places
like Bolivia, but in
the middle of the US.
They're designing around open
space and intensive agriculture
agroforestry, smaller scale.
Just to show you what this
is in terms of the data,
living 12 by 12, or
living more simply,
it does actually bring joy
because, actually, happiness
and well-being increases
very quickly if you're poor,
if you're very poor--
like $9,000 in GDP.
But then it kind of plateaus.
So this is the basic idea,
that happiness, of course,
it goes up with money, but
then it plateaus is the idea.
So when I came back to New York
City after living in the 12
by 12, I found that
our townhouse that we
own in Queens, my wife
and I, was just too big.
It was 2000 square feet.
So we moved to this
tiny apartment.
This is just examples--
this is not our apartment--
but of a micro apartment in
Manhattan, 340 square feet.
So it was like two 12
by 12s put together.
And we experimented
for a year living
very minimalist in the belly
of the beast, New York City.
And it was actually
quite fascinating
because we started to
see our micro apartment--
and by the way, this is part
of Bloomberg's initiative
for everyone to live in smaller
apartments, lower rents and so
on-- we thought of it as a ship.
We designed it as a ship.
Everything had its place.
There was no more clutter.
We just felt, in
some ways, happier
because we knew where everything
was and we had less stuff
to worry about.
So there was some
advantages to minimalizing
and you know, lower rents.
I also reduced my working
hours by a lot, basically
to the three hour work
week that Carlos Slim
is calling for--
three day work week.
And I just think that these
technologies that you all
are involved in are beautiful
things if they're your tool
and you're not their fool.
If you're actually using
them for liberating yourself
from the work and
spend treadmill,
from giving yourself
more free time
to enjoy your family,
friends, nature, your hobbies,
what you love to do.
Think of things
that you love to do
and imagine doing them five
times more than you are right
now.
I hope this is not too
subversive a thought
for being in the office
on a Monday morning.
But the idea is that I was
working, honestly, a two
day work week for the
good part of that year
that we lived slow,
and just enjoying
so much more about the city.
And just working smarter
instead of harder
and it was this whole
other philosophy.
Really, just to switch it, what
it comes down to, in some ways,
is a Greek word
that Aristotle used
to talk about a lot,
which is eudaimonia.
It's "what is the best life."
That's what the Greeks
would struggle with,
and that's what
we don't struggle
with enough these days.
It's like, what is
the economy for?
What is work for?
How do we create this best life?
I'm not going to give you
my entire graduate course
in economic development
right now, but just
to let you know that there are
various perspectives on what
development is.
OK?
What we think is development
is growth economics.
That's the dominant paradigm.
And then there's
a hybrid of that,
which is the human development
paradigm, like the HDI
index, which says, oh we should
bring people into development.
It's not just about
growing economies.
We have to think about people.
But there are these
wonderful critiques,
innovators in theory and
practice and development
who are saying, biocentrism,
post development-- I recommend
Arturo Escobar.
He has a book called
"Encountering Developments",
which is genius.
David Abrams' work on "The
Spell of the Sensuous",
more biocentric points of views.
Escobar, for example,
this anthropologist
says we need to look at
the West, our own culture,
as exotic.
Very difficult to do,
but this is exotic,
this kind of deforestation,
this is exotic.
So there's the
country of Nacirema,
do you know where that is?
Nacirema, have
you heard of this?
AUDIENCE: Backwards America.
BILL POWERS: Exactly.
It's American spelled backwards.
So you just reverse
the way you look
at our own culture for a second.
It looks very different.
This we talked about,
biocentrism and expanding
emotional connection to nature.
Very key ideas of-- even when
you think about your work
at Google, or how you
organize your time and so
on, is it possible
for a second to look
at things from the
perspective of other species,
not just an anthropocentric
point of view of how this
benefits our species, but
how it benefits the whole?
And you immediately have this
shift in your consciousness,
where you just feel more
aligned with the world.
You feel happier.
You feel like what you're
doing is more inclusive.
I'm not saying you
have to become a vegan,
and I'm not a vegetarian myself.
But I'm just saying that
there's this way of seeing
the world that's very
different from how we see it.
And these more critical
development theorists
are pointing that way.
You are now entering
a stress free zone.
So the point of this
is that-- I just want
to share most recently--
we, my wife and I,
took another kind
of experimental step
because we're always
kind of life hacking,
figuring out how to do things
differently and experimenting.
Because you only
live once and you
might as well push
your boundaries.
So we actually
moved from New York
after we were there
for five years.
We moved down to Bolivia.
So now I'm coming to
you here from a town
of 4,000 people,
where the Andes meets
the Amazon in central Bolivia.
It's a beautiful town
called called Samaipata.
It's where the Andes
elbows into the Amazon.
So you see it's like
forested-- this is Samaipata--
but also there's
mountainous climate.
And there's people
from 30 countries here.
A lot of people are
innovating around
different aspects of
what I'm talking about.
Slow money, slow
living, permaculture,
which is combining
architecture with landscape
design in harmony with
nature, all these ideas.
And it's a very
beautiful place to be.
Also right now,
in Bolivia, do you
know that they have the Law
of Mother Earth as their macro
law?
It sounds kind of crazy.
But the idea is that the earth
has nine indelible rights,
and you can sue
corporations for violating
the rights of Pachamama,
as they call it.
So for them the
most important thing
is Pachamama, because
all life comes from that.
And so the right to life and
to exist, vital functions
of the ecosystem, all
of that is legislated.
Now, they're not perfect
in implementing it,
but they do have this new
framework that they're saying.
So a lot of what we're doing at
the local level in a transition
town relates to the
national policy.
And Bolivia is kind of
basing some other stuff
around the fact that-- this is
another way of looking at what
I showed you before--
as personal income
increases, the percentage of
people identifying themselves
as very happy stays the same.
This is in the United
States over the years.
So they're saying, OK well
if that's the case then
how do you have a
living well policy?
And that's, by the
way, what Bolivia
has as their other sort
of norm is living well.
Have you heard of this?
Living well, vivir
bien, in Spanish?
What's our philosophy in the US?
Is it vivir bien?
Is it living well, or
what would you say it is?
What's the dominant ethos?
AUDIENCE: Work hard, play hard.
BILL POWERS: Work
hard, play hard?
That's probably Google's ethos,
but what about the American--
maybe work hard, play hard--
but what would you say?
More.
Yeah, more.
Better, right?
Living better.
In Bolivia, it's Quechua,
Aymara, Guarani, Chiquitano,
it's an indigenous country.
It's 75% indigenous.
Their philosophy is living well.
So you get to a certain
point of development,
like whatever, you know
like the other graph
where you get to
certain point, and then
you have a steady state economy.
That's what Herman Daly
has been telling us
for years-- this
famous economist-- that
just like the human body
grows to a certain level
and then stops growing
and maintains equilibrium
and health, so too
should our economy grow
to a certain level
and then not have
to have this hyper
development path.
So Bolivia is playing
with that creative edge
of how to do an economy
at a national level
according to living
well and not better.
It's an interesting thing.
Just to show you, this is our
house that we just finished.
Small house, we used some
of the minimalism design.
This whole house we built out
of adobe from our own land.
This is where the
adobe was dug up.
It's thermal mass 40 cm.
It maintains 22 degrees Celsius
all year round with no heating
or cooling because of the adobe.
There was no embedded
carbon because it was just
baked by the sun right
there on our property.
And it's beautiful.
We have beautiful
windows and double doors,
but it's minimalist,
beautiful and ecological.
Like all of our waste is
reused, it goes to banana trees.
The sewage goes into a
tank that gets filtered
through different
plants and everything.
And the grey water is
going to a composting area.
So this is what we're kind
of experimenting with there,
another example of
ecological architecture.
I like this cartoon.
So you know, what if we created
a better world for nothing?
That's almost like
the best you can say.
I think we need to just keep
pushing our boundaries, just
to sum up what I've
been talking about.
Getting more creative,
keeping in mind
the Earth's biophysical
limits in our decisions,
having a more ecocentric
point of view,
trying to find more happiness
and joy in work life balance,
all of this is tied together.
All of it's tied to the big
challenge of our time, which
is confronting this
culture of fast and more
that's contributing to ecocide,
or the destruction of life's
vital processes, and
finding new system.
A system that's based more in
principles of a steady state
economy, of transition towns,
of a slower, saner, fit
for the future type of a life.
And I think every single
one of us has a role.
Like in this room,
whatever you're
doing here or in your
civic organizations
in your free time or whatever,
you have a role in this change.
And I would just
encourage you to think
about what that role could be.
And I hope that you read
my book "New Slow City",
which Jonathan was nice
enough to get for all of you.
The book is not really lecturing
as to what you should do,
but I think it's opening
up a lot of questions
about ways that we
can push ourselves
to think about these things more
deeply, enjoy life more fully,
be less tethered to
other people's agendas
and to big systems of control.
And I hope that you
enjoyed this presentation.
I'm happy to answer
any questions you have.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL POWERS: Yes?
AUDIENCE: On the previous
slide, what are we
looking at on the bottom right?
BILL POWERS: Well this is what's
called skyscraper agriculture.
So in just one
recycled tower like
that you can produce food
for like 50 square blocks.
This is Brooklyn Grange,
it's an idea, it's a model.
This is Brooklyn Grange in
Long Island City, New York,
where I take my
students for NYU.
It was started by NYU students.
It's the world's largest
rooftop organic farm.
So on the old
Standard Oil building,
they produce well over an
acre of intensively cropped
organic agriculture that
just goes on the subway
and goes to the restaurants
in New York City.
It's a brilliant idea.
It's employing all these people.
They're outside working.
They're on the
roof of a building.
They have all these
new ultralight soils
that can go on the roof.
So this is what
exists now, and one
of the ideas for the future.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What do you think
of vertical agriculture
and how far has it come.
How close is it
[INAUDIBLE] being achieved?
BILL POWERS: It's
expanding rapidly.
Like in New York,
this Brooklyn Grange
expanded 150 percent last
year to the Brooklyn Navy Yard
rooftops that they've
now taken over.
On a commercial level there's
greenhouse rooftop agriculture
coming in.
This is soil farms, that's
even more productive.
These new soils that
they have, and it's
easy to use a variety
of roofs-- if they just
used 10% of New York's
roofs they could feed
the entire city-- but
there's also, let's
not forget, 600 green
thumb community gardens
that are provided sometimes
by the city, where people
are doing urban agriculture in
lots and producing lots of food
on the ground, too.
So that's another important
part of the picture.
Yeah, OK.
So?
AUDIENCE: I just had a question.
How do you make
money while you're
living in Bolivia [INAUDIBLE]?
BILL POWERS: How
do I make money?
Well, so do you
know Juliet Schor
the economist at Boston College?
She wrote a lot about this.
She has a book
called "True Wealth",
where she talks about
self-provisioning.
So in the new economy, those
of us sitting in this room
are lucky enough to have
these types of skills
that be done anywhere.
Like that photo I have of
the woman with her laptop
and her feet in
the water, that's
what I love about these
wonderful tools is you
can be anywhere.
For me personally, I have
multiple income streams from
different things-- from speaking
engagements, from writing,
from teaching, from--
AUDIENCE: --travel to the
place where you write, then
you had to have power
to power your device.
BILL POWERS: Right, that's true.
Well so power, we're
actually set up for solar,
but, as of now,
we're using the town
power, which is natural gas.
Yeah.
So we're not saying
that you have
to be a radical, off the grid,
self sufficient lifestyle.
I mean, that's possible,
but I talk about it
as part of being
self sufficient-ish.
Right?
Kind of self sufficient.
So we're able to produce
a lot of our food
just right there in front of
that little house that you saw.
We produce a lot of
our food year round.
And we have 30 kinds
of fruit trees growing
and everything else.
We're developing a
little cottage industry
kind of on the land,
as one income stream.
There's the writing, my wife
does a little bit of consulting
at the UN, like
three months a year.
So you piece that all together
and it adds up to plenty.
And if you've minimized
your expenses, too you know.
And that's another thing.
I recommend Vicki Robin
and Joe Dominguez's book
"Your Money or Your
Life", which shows you
how to really look at
what expenses in your life
don't give you the proper
joy to stuff ratio.
You know?
Like how much joy
are you getting out
of a particular purchase,
that type of an idea.
We did that.
We analyzed it very carefully
and we reduced our expenses
by lot.
And we also look
at, like OK, how
do you increase
your hourly income
in a certain amount of time.
Even some of the
Tim Ferriss stuff
about like 80/20 principle,
that you get 20% of your results
from 80% of your activity.
So why not do more
in the 20% that
gives you 80% of the results?
So working smarter in that way.
So these are all a
package of things
that we've applied to
achieve an independence
from the typical work system.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
children to support?
BILL POWERS: Yes I do.
I've got two children.
Two daughters, ages one
and a half, and nine.
Yeah, I think like, for
example, raising them
in Bolivia versus New
York City is, for me,
far better because
you're in a culture that
is more ecocentric,
more indigenous.
They're very nature-based.
And quite frankly,
we're not tied to work,
so we're with our
kids all the time.
You know, it's like
we're able to just
be with them a lot more.
And they're very in-tuned
to our little creek
and to the fruit trees, and
they're growing up bilingual.
There's lots of advantages.
I'm not saying that everyone
has to move to Bolivia,
and you're probably
not going to,
but for us, that
was one edge to push
that I thought was
really interesting.
AUDIENCE: I was actually
going to ask you
what led you to that
town in Bolivia?
And were there other
places you considered?
BILL POWERS: Well,
you know, Samaipata,
which is a Quechua word for
resting in the highlands,
happened to just really
attract both of us.
I think that everyone would have
their own place in the world
that they feel best.
But for us, I had a
writing fellowship there
once that they had this
artist's house there that I went
and, wow!
Just like, low cost of
living, relatively speaking,
which is true anywhere
in the developing world.
And just beautiful national
park and Inca ruins,
and just this gorgeous
kind of a place to live,
good climate year round.
But also just the fact
that you can kind of,
we call it decolonizing--
sorry that's
a very academic
term-- decolonizing
some of our ingrained
habits of over consumption
and competitiveness
that we found.
We're both from Ivy League
colleges and all this stuff,
and from a certain background.
But we're kinds of decolonizing
a little bit of that ethos.
And we thought that Samaipata
would be a good place to do it
and it is.
It really is.
AUDIENCE: Are there other
people sharing your [INAUDIBLE]?
BILL POWERS: Absolutely.
There are.
Yeah there are.
In fact, like I said,
there are people
from 30 countries
that have come there.
It's still only 5% of the
village is foreigners, mostly
Bolivian, which is
nice, nice balance.
But there's
definitely a community
of like-- our friends are
ecological architects,
like the one who designed
our house-- everyone
lives in the town.
And 80% of what we consume is
produced there in the town.
So it's very local and
organic and everything else.
There are hardships, of course.
Not easy, it's not like here.
I come back to the
States and you pop up
on the T in Kendall
Square and it
has all those beautiful
buildings and stuff like that.
It's harder.
It's on the land.
There's a dirt road
going to our house,
even though we live
right by the village.
You're working more,
but like I said,
humans are a tough species.
We can adapt to these things.
Actually, harder is better.
I can do hard.
I like that.
I like having to struggle
a little bit more
and not having it be too easy.
That's my perspective.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So especially
with multiple jobs
and you say you work harder.
I'm having a difficult
time balancing that
with your statement of
working three days, not four.
What does working
mean and what do you
do with those other four?
Are they really
not-- just curious.
BILL POWERS: So did
everyone hear that question
about what am I doing
the other four days?
Oh you didn't hear it?
He's just saying
how is it possible--
I'm mentioning all these
different things that I'm
doing, how is it possible that
there's actually the free time?
Right?
AUDIENCE: Well, just yeah.
What are you defining
the free time as?
BILL POWERS: That's
a great question.
But I definitely, when I
was doing the two day work
week-- which went to a four
day work week in New York
halfway through the book, kind
of had to change, but still
three day weekends-- I clocked
in every five minute interval.
Whenever I was an a laptop at
all or doing anything related
to an income stream,
that was work,
and it counted towards my two,
or three, or four day work
week.
OK?
Now, because we take
these big creativity
sabbaticals where we're
not doing anything
and we disconnect
from devices and take
these internet sabbaticals
and so on, and vacation auto
response, and we just tune out.
Like a lot of times we're just
like concentrated on growing
food, hiking, going back
to beautiful places hiking,
we love to be outside,
being with family
in a non-connected
way through work.
The problem is the
work constantly
comes through the phone.
AUDIENCE: So you call growing
food part of the non work?
BILL POWERS: Yes, definitely.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's what I
was going to ask you, too.
So food production is not
part of your income stream?
BILL POWERS: Well it is in
the sense that it's, yeah,
it is self-provisioning.
But it just doesn't
feel like work
at the level we're doing it.
It's not like we
have this huge farm.
We're producing it just
intensively around the house
and fruit tree
production, and so on,
like maybe 10 hours
a week or less
that we're actually
putting into it.
We're not turning
into this big thing.
I guess what I didn't say is a
lot of really what this comes
down to-- and I don't know if
this appeals to you or not--
but for me and for my wife and
our kids, what appeals to us
is doing nothing, too.
I mean, oh god, it
sounds so radical.
But taking four or five hours
a day and just doing nothing,
like just walking behind our
house, or just meditation.
Or literally, and
this sounds crazy,
like walking to your neighbors
and just hanging out with them.
Like people do that
in this village.
You just stop by and
have tea with someone.
Or you just sit in your
hammock for a couple hours,
like all of these things.
It's like the way
we used to live
when I was a kid in the
'70s, or something like that.
Before we got into this
culture of a lot of speed,
it's that more relaxed
summer vacation type of feel
that we bring to
our whole lives.
Does that make sense?
So we consciously
integrate all of that
into our lives, that free
time and that nothing time.
It comes actually out of Africa.
I lived in Africa for a couple
years, and what I realized
was that people had to spend
four or five hours a day
doing nothing, playing soccer,
sitting in the hammocks,
or they weren't happy.
They have this leisure ethic
instead of a work ethic.
And that's kind
of what taught me
about this idea of not
always being-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why no wood
stove in the cabin?
BILL POWERS: Why no wood
stove in the 12 by 12?
There is a space
for a wood stove,
and the physician that
lives there to this day
could've put one
in, but she did not.
She decided that she
was just perfectly happy
being cold when it got cold
and putting on extra layers
and making more tea.
AUDIENCE: Cold when
it's 10 below outside?
BILL POWERS: Well, I mean,
it is North Carolina.
So it's not Boston.
So it gets down to 20,
sometimes, at the coldest.
But it's usually like 30s
or 40s at the very coldest.
AUDIENCE: Is there a washroom?
BILL POWERS: In the 12 by 12?
OK.
The 12 by 12 has two porches
in the front the back.
And the back porch has
a composting toilet.
There's this-- have you
heard of, you probably
haven't-- but it's called
the "Humanure Handbook."
It's a contraction of human
manure, "Humanure Handbook."
Teaches you all the different
types of composting toilets
you can make.
That was right there on
the shelf when I arrived.
And I had to figure
how to use this thing.
But basically, you go
out on the back porch
and it's like a five
gallon bucket, hidden,
and then there's a toilet seat.
And there are cedar
chips beside it.
And when it fills up, you
just dump it in a compost pile
and it becomes compost.
That's it.
It's very simple.
It doesn't smell at all.
And then the water for
washing was a solar shower
that I'd put out in the morning.
The sun would heat it up.
You hang it from a
tree and you shower.
And then, the water for
washing up dishes and stuff
was also on the back porch.
And that's just from rainwater
catchment from the house.
So she's got this whole system
that she applies and lives off
of.
It liberates her time.
She donates her time
as a doctor now.
She doesn't even have to
really work for money.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I don't know if
this is a legitimate question.
Help me form it into a question.
How much land do you
need of agriculture
for a person to live off of?
BILL POWERS: That's
a great question.
Jonathan, is it
possible to pass me
that-- I guess I
could just grab it.
If you'll just pass me
that bottle of water?
Four and 1/2 acres is
what-- OK, the question
is how much land you need
to live off of, right?
Thanks a lot.
Agronomists have said that with
four and a half acres, which
is a little bit-- we
have five, five and 1/2--
every person on the
planet, even all
seven billion people
organized in families--
could have 4 and 1/2 acres each
and live very sustainably off
of that.
And there would be
lots of wild forests
and lots of conservation.
Doesn't sound
realistic, but it is.
There's a lot of
acreage we're using just
in ridiculously
ineffective ways.
AUDIENCE: So 4 and 1/2
per person, per family?
BILL POWERS: Per family.
Yeah.
We could easily
live off our land.
I mean, the soil
is so productive--
AUDIENCE: Not living
in Somerville.
BILL POWERS: Not
living in Somerville.
Yeah.
I'm just saying you could, think
about it, anyone in this room,
either this year or
within five years easily,
could do what we did
if you wanted to.
You could liquidate
what you have here
and get something so
beautiful somewhere else where
the cost of living is
lower and you could do it.
I'm not saying you're gonna.
But you have that power
and the resources.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
you were [INAUDIBLE].
Is that the case?
BILL POWERS: I still am on
the adjunct faculty at NYU
and I bring students to Bolivia
and I teach the sustainable
development global
field intensive,
where we look at models of
how to develop sustainably.
Like with these
graduates students.
So I'm not on a sabbatical.
I meant like I'm on a
creativity sabbatical that
means-- we come up
with our own lexicon.
I don't know if you ever read
"Mountains Beyond Mountains",
Paul Farmer, the
physician at Harvard.
They created the whole lexicon
around poverty, reduction,
and so on.
We have a whole lexicon
around all this stuff.
So creativity
sabbaticals just means
I'm not going to work
for, like, two months,
and we're going to
just develop new ideas.
Whatever we want.
Like in other words, we're
not tied to anyone else.
So we're going to come up
with new-- that's what it is.
So writing a new book.
Whatever creative
project, starting
some kind of cottage industry.
Whatever it is, that's
our creativity sabbatical.
AUDIENCE: I was asking do
you have an end date to leave
your life over
there and come back?
BILL POWERS: Do I
have an end date
to leave my life over
there and come back?
No.
Not really.
I mean, we do have
our place in New York.
We just rent it out.
Another income stream.
But--
AUDIENCE: I was asking because
your approach to your life
could have been different if
you had a time limit applied.
OK.
I will live there like
two years and then
I will go back to my other life.
BILL POWERS: As far
as we're concerned,
I've never been happier
than I am now in this town,
living at this smallest
beautiful scale with community.
Everyone knows me.
We have beautiful nature.
It's like, what
more could we want?
In terms of having the absolute
best schools and so on,
I mean, again that's
another idea in our heads
that you have to have
the perfect everything
for your kids.
So I'm notching that down.
I'm realizing that
Amaya and Clea may not
have the absolute
best of everything.
We're going to give them a
wonderful life and education
and basis and they
can go from there.
But maybe it won't be even
the level my wife and I had.
But it's like, I do think that
this kind of disease-- you
might even call it a disease--
around kind of over educating
our kids or
overstimulating them.
Like this sort of
helicopter parenting
and over scheduling kids is not
going in the right direction,
in my opinion.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What are some of
the most surprising things you
learned about yourself in this
transition to live slowly?
BILL POWERS: What are the
most surprising things
I learned about myself in
this transition to living
more slowly?
That you can find a lot
more happiness and joy
in unexpected ways.
That when you tie your
self esteem and everything
to your position in life
and your amount of income
and your status, you're
bound to always be unhappy
because there's
always someone higher.
As soon as you get
rid of that idea,
and you step out of this culture
and into a culture like Bolivia
where nobody has those ideas,
or it's a very low idea.
Much higher is how
interconnected are you
with others.
It's like people are people
through other people.
It surprised me that,
oh, I get self esteem
from just being
helpful to people
and being part of this group.
So that's one of the things.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Just one thought.
A couple family friends
who sort of downsized,
one challenge, especially in the
US, is their medical expenses.
Say you reduce
your income and you
live-- I have a friend who's
a captain on a boat, lives
on a boat.
Very low income.
Another one a
perpetually touring band,
another one in a small cabin.
You know?
And it's great, but
the US is particularly
challenged because the
medical system we have.
You see anything in
different cultures that
or are economists
thinking about that?
BILL POWERS: I'm amazed at how
a country like Bolivia, which
is the second poorest,
economically, in Latin America
has almost a better
medical system than we do.
For our baby daughter,
a doctor would
come like every two months to
our house and check up on her
and then give her the
shots there with the nurse.
This whole team would come.
They'd go around to
everyone's house and do it.
How are they able to do that?
My mom was down visiting.
She had an accident.
We went to the hospital
in Samaipata there.
They treated her
right away and it
was 30 Bolivianos was the bill.
Four dollars.
I don't understand.
It's a socialist government.
The government is socialist.
And they have these policies
they're redistributing.
They tax the companys
at high levels,
like the oil and gas companies,
the mining companies,
and they just redistribute
to health and education.
So that's part of it.
And so it's
universal, basically.
The care, obviously, is not
the Harvard Medical School
facility, obviously.
Again, we've seen
it as accepting
a slightly lower level of care.
You know, we can go to
Santa Cruz two hours away
if we really needed
something that
was US level or close to it.
But on a daily
basis, we're not tied
into super high powered medical.
We do have insurance.
Someone like us
living-- you can have
an evacuation plan, very cheap.
And you can have
catastrophic, like where
you pay a deductible,
and then for a couple
hundred dollars a
month or, something,
you're covered for your family.
So it's totally doable.
AUDIENCE: How much of this
is made possible by the fact
that on a global
scale you're wealthy.
You were born in the US.
So therefore, on a
global scale, you
have resources that a
lot of people don't have.
How much would this be possible
for everyone in the world.
BILL POWERS: OK.
This is not a transferable
model to anyone in the world.
It's a transfer model
to anyone in this room.
And I'm talking to you
about it in this way.
But there's a whole
other conversation
that we could be having.
Which is the fact that
people in Bolivia,
like in this town of
4,000 people, for example,
the well being levels,
the happiness levels which
we looked at are very high.
It's like 90%.
OK?
And people are living at very
low levels of consumption
without having to
decolonize their thoughts
or simplify or anything.
They're already there.
So it's this myth we have of
we equate subsistence living,
living sustainably and
simply, with poverty.
It was one of the
greatest injustices
of defining under development
in that way, in that we have
to bring this gift of
development to the third world,
and so on.
No.
Part of this is
like a south north
education of looking at the
gifts and the ways of life
people have in countries
that are indigenous,
and what we can learn
from it and take from it.
So it's a different
type of a way
of thinking about it that's hard
to explain in a short lecture.
But there's all kinds of books
about this, too, and films.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] do
they want to come to America?
BILL POWERS: It's a combination.
I mean, as you know,
everything's complex.
But in Santa Cruz in
the city, the capital
where the mall is, and
everything like that, obviously
people look towards
Miami and towards the US.
And then there's
another group of lots
of people who are
quite content and happy
and not looking that way.
So it's hybrid.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BILL POWERS: Sure.
Any other questions
maybe from somebody
who hasn't had one yet?
What do you all think?
Were there any thoughts, ideas?
AUDIENCE: The graphs
you showed earlier
that showed the
amount of money people
earned over the last 50
or 60 years in the US,
are they taking into
account inflation?
BILL POWERS: Yes.
It was adjusted for inflation.
Right, so the happiness studies,
or the well-being studies
that are done through
various universities
are like, how happy do you feel?
How satisfied do you
feel with your life?
And people say how
satisfied they are.
And you just do it each year.
And then you look at the trend.
And it's just showing that, when
you look at wealth increase,
it's not making you happier
after a certain point.
AUDIENCE: I had a question.
You were talking about
writing a new book.
What technology are
you using to write it?
BILL POWERS: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: What technology
are you using to write it?
BILL POWERS: Oh!
OK.
What technology am
I using to write it?
Yeah.
I mean, this is my
laptop right here.
I use just a regular PC laptop.
I often will dictate things
onto a digital voice recorder
and then my intern
will transcribe it,
or I'll-- well usually
my intern will do it.
And then I use like
right-brained activities.
Like, there's this book
"Writing on the Right
Side of the Brain", which
I got many years ago.
And it's like, you do
clustering, mind mapping.
I guess you guys use tools
for that on the internet,
but I just use a notebook.
You have different
colored pens and stuff,
and you write the concepts and
you branch out into new ideas.
Yeah, you guys do this right,
like on whiteboards and stuff.
Then you hit an idea
that's a purple patch
or like an energized
stream of ideas.
And then that's your idea
you're going to write about.
And you branch out from there.
So it's a right brained way of
generating ideas and material.
AUDIENCE: More generally,
what's the level
of technology penetration
in your village?
BILL POWERS: Oh my village!
OK, so low, I would
say, but growing.
I mean it's a mix.
I don't use a
smartphone in Bolivia.
Just a line that I've drawn.
I don't want to model
too much connectedness.
I have one here.
But my wife and
I don't use that.
There is Wi-Fi in
our village, so we're
able to-- like there's
Wi-Fi everywhere--
so we're able to
work and stream Skype
and so on from the village.
But I would say
95% of the people
don't have computers
in their homes.
Only 10% of people,
no less, have cars.
5% of people have
cars in our village.
We don't have a car.
Another wonderful thing
about this small living
and dense living like that,
is you don't need cars.
Lots of public transportation.
So I don't know.
It's like one of those
questions for you all.
What do you think about
the way that technology
is starting to penetrate
a village like Samaipata?
It's bringing video games
in, very violent video games
into the internet
cafes in the center.
There's a lot of
commercial content,
lots of it coming through.
Like the DeVargas
mall I showed you,
they are advertising like
crazy over the web, too.
Facebook ads and
everything else.
So I mean, there's
that question,
that double edged
sword where it can
be very liberating for people,
of course, to have these tools.
But on the other
hand it's definitely
changing their whole way
of life and their ethos.
So I'm not sure if you guys
ever have that discussion
about the ethics of creating
certain technologies
and exporting them to places.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
BILL POWERS: Yeah.
OK.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
Carlos Slim talking
about the three
day or four day--
BILL POWERS: He's advocating
for a three day work week.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so that's
very interesting to hear.
What led him to
that declaration?
BILL POWERS: How many
people have heard of this?
Did you read about this?
Was it on CNN and everything?
Did anyone hear about
the three day work week?
OK you did.
All right.
AUDIENCE: I've actually proposed
it to people that I work with.
BILL POWERS: Oh you have?
Really?
And what's been the feedback?
AUDIENCE: They think I'm crazy.
BILL POWERS: We'll just say
the world's richest man--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
If you're Carlos Slim you can
propose just about anything.
BILL POWERS: He's an older man.
AUDIENCE: What is it that
he's like advocating for,
like everyone and--
BILL POWERS: Yeah,
universal policy, he
wants a three day work week.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering.
BILL POWERS: Yeah.
I mean he's Mexican.
So first of all he's
Mexican, isn't that right?
He's Mexican.
Latin America, by the way,
the happiness indicators
are much higher than in
other areas of the world.
I think he just
realizes that life
is about extended family,
about time, and other things
besides just making money.
He's like, oh crap, I'm
like whatever, 70 years old
and now I'm realizing.
And he wants to give that gift
to people of, like, free time.
I think he also sees
it as more efficient.
Like you get your work
done, and then you're done.
You refresh, and you come back.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
three day work week,
but you have two
shifts, and so you're
getting six day work weeks.
BILL POWERS: But like--
AUDIENCE: I'm not
trying to be cynical.
BILL POWERS: But isn't it
great to batch your work?
Like I love batching stuff.
I love to work in
intensive periods,
and then you're
done for a while.
I think that's part of the idea.
AUDIENCE: The appeal of mine
was we could work five days
and be off for two.
Or we could do like
50/50. [INAUDIBLE]
as a better balance.
Like I don't even know what
led to a five day work week.
I know that legislation went
to [INAUDIBLE] labor laws
in the US.
Now it just seems like something
that businesses get to decide.
BILL POWERS: Exactly.
And labor movement's
pushed very hard like,
did you know the big slogan in
the American labor movement,
when there actually were
unions a hundred years ago?
Bread and roses, that
was on the banners.
And do you know what that meant?
Give us bread, yes
give us higher pay.
But also time to
smell the roses.
That's really what they
were advocating for.
And unfortunately,
we lost the roses.
As I showed you,
the working hours
have gone up considerably, and
all that benefit of free time.
And unions are only, what,
9% right now of the country
or less.
They've lost that.
I know that there's some battles
about vacation time going on
now.
Like I just saw how
the Tribune, which
owns the "LA Times," there was
a revolt in the whole workforce
because they tried to push
through this other vacation,
like taking away the
discretionary days, sick days,
and vacation days, and just
have it all packaged into one.
But it was a subtle
way of taking away
their vacation time.
Anyway, this erosion of what
is the idea of time off.
AUDIENCE: I very clearly
remember that the day I
met someone who was from
Europe working [INAUDIBLE].
And he was like, oh yeah, we
get like by default six weeks
vacation.
And then like my
head spun around.
That's when I was very
young in my technical career
and it was like two weeks.
I think the chart about
the number of days
people are taking off
is very interesting.
BILL POWERS: How many
weeks off do you all get?
AUDIENCE: A lot.
AUDIENCE: I'm at six weeks now,
but I've been on for ten years.
BILL POWERS: Wow.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: Entry is three.
BILL POWERS: Three?
Three Is the entry?
OK.
But still, three weeks
is a very small amount.
And do people actually take
even all of their vacation days
here?
Because 40% of Americans
don't even take their full
2 and 1/2 weeks of vacation.
They lose those days.
41%, it's amazing.
But people here actually
take your six weeks?
OK.
Try to, OK.
At least you're honest.
All right.
Well if there's
nothing else, I just
wanted to say just in
conclusion that I'm just
very happy to have been
here with you today.
And I just think this is some of
the most intelligent questions
I've had in a while, which
I think is really great.
And I can tell that you all
are thinking a lot about this.
Even the fact that you came
here today on a Monday morning
to talk about these
ideas of slow and finding
more happiness and
work life balance,
and thinking about your role
in the environmental crisis
and everything else.
Like that's just phenomenal and
shows that you guys are leaders
here at Google.
I appreciated very
much that opportunity
to be here with you.
Thank you for inviting me.
And I hope that
you enjoy the book.
Also, oh, you do
have some books here.
Oh wow, they just came just now.
OK.
Sometimes when you
get something for free
maybe you don't
appreciate it as much,
but hopefully you'll
actually read it and then
pass it on to
somebody else to read.
Thank you so much.
Have a great day.
[APPLAUSE]